con 8 años lily es una niña llena de
vida
sin embargo no siempre se ha sentido
bien en su sede por haber nacido en un
cuerpo de niño el año pasado vivió un
periodo de profunda depresión
fue creciendo con el paso de las noches
vamos hacia la lista de los métodos en
los que había pensado para poder morir
sin fallar en efecto cuando una noche
logró decirnos por qué su vida era tan
nula y lo que quería cambiar para que
fuese soportable lo vivimos como un
alivio
nos dijimos sabemos lo que la está
afectando entonces haremos todo lo
posible para que se sienta menos mal
pinchamos
primera lucha durante el ingreso a
clases la academia se resiste a aceptar
el cambio de nombre de lille y sus
padres ganan
mata
o no
en la escuela no hay inconveniente con
la explicación de la transición de lilly
a sus amigos un reconocimiento esencial
para la niña así no todo esté despejado
para el ibi
a veces hay grandes lamentos en la noche
porque vive como una injusticia a veces
lo reivindica y está contenta con ello y
a veces se siente estigmatizado y
cristaliza en sus dificultades y se dice
porque me diferencia entonces le
ayudamos y demostramos porque su
diferencia es bella
para ello christel y guillaume se
volcaron hacia asociaciones de
acompañamiento para personas transgénero
información grupo de conversación
escucha aquí encontraron un gran apoyo
gracias a estos voluntarios los niños se
encuentran muy aislados en su vivencia
del cambio de identidad pero los padres
no saben dónde encontrar ayuda teniendo
y qué suerte es cierto que los padres
siguen preguntándose si hay que escuchar
al niño siempre es el discurso médico un
discurso a veces estigmatizante con
médicos que no siempre toman en serio el
cambio de identidad
hay una forma de negación a negar la
existencia de los trances no hará que
los trans no existan es una realidad
creo que es importante decir que hay
niños trans con fe
que es posible ser trans muy pequeño y
que existe la posibilidad de acompañar
nos acompaña pero en francia aún no hay
muchas estructuras especializadas en
ayudar a estos niños nacidos en el
cuerpo equivocado la mayoría de ellas se
encuentran en parís psiquiatra y
terapeuta familiar
sergi jefe se creó hace algunos años un
protocolo en el hospital pitié
salpétriére para acompañar a los
adolescentes en transición a estos
jóvenes que muy jóvenes no se sienten en
el género correcto no quiere decir que
tendrán a los 15 16 18 o 20 años un
recorrido de cambio de identidad sin
embargo los jóvenes que tienen 13 o 14
años en la pubertad que se sienten
afectados por los cambios de su cuerpo
eso sí están con frecuencia en un
recorrido de cambio de identidad es
decir que en un momento dado querrán
tomar hormonas hacerse una cirugía para
adaptar su cuerpo a la forma en la que
se representan en su interior
pero antes de ello a estos adolescentes
se les pueden prescribir medicamentos
que retrasan la pubertad de algunos años
así pueden reflexionar sobre lo que
desea un lapso esencial según sergi
jefes que ve cada vez más adolescentes
influenciados por internet y las redes
sociales se hacen preguntas pero de
repente estarán en contacto con otros
diez jóvenes que diría yo hice tal
recorrido yo meto meta al tratamiento
vía tal cirujano etcétera mi vida ha
sido transformada es maravilloso y creo
que hay que desconfiar un poco de ello
porque les da referencias un poco
rápidas pero creo que hay que
reflexionar es importante que estos
menores sean aceptados y apoyados por su
familia lo que no es evidente según este
sociólogo según un estudio de 2014 el 40
por ciento de personas transgénero se
distanciaron o perdieron contacto con un
miembro de la familia sin no pasos
decisivos de la paga de los pagos
para un niño que consulta con sus padres
que han aceptado esta decisión habrá 10
20 30 100 que no consultará nunca a sus
padres tendrán que esperar su
emancipación para poder emprender
trámites y una transición no es tan sólo
una transición médica tenemos tendencia
a reducirlo a ello pero en realidad es
ante todo un cambio social un cambio de
estatus social una transformación social
social
una transformación que ya empezó para
lilly
próxima etapa cambiar su nombre en su
estado civil
sus padres iniciaron los trámites por
ella